I could not have written ready player 1
if I had not grown up on a steady diet
of Steven Spielberg movies it would have
been a different story or I might not
have written it at all his work is woven
into the fabric of my life
everybody I think who dreams of making
movies dreams of getting to work with
him it's a dream come true
[Music]
when I read ready player one it was the
most amazing flash-forward and flashback
at the same time I was born in 2025 but
I wish I'd grown up in the 1980s my
Khalid a and Laura like all my heroes I
suddenly saw a future that earned his
client the writer of the book envisioned
it wasn't that far away from what I
think is going to happen someday I live
here in Columbus Ohio in 2045 Columbus
is the fastest-growing city on earth but
it sure doesn't seem like it when you
live in the stacks there's a dystopian
society and the fabric of our economy is
crumbling it's a good time to escape so
virtual reality will be a super drug
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
[Music]
I was very careful with Ernie
collaborating with me every step of the
way to be able to find the movie
narrative inside this dense forest of
Ernie's so found imagination
the Oasis being the ultimate toy box
with all the toys in the world and then
playing that with one of the greatest
filmmakers of all time it results in
just amazing action and such a fun
adventure
[Music]
ernest cline is such a visionary and i
has seen the future before any of us
possibly could even imagine it
[Music]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
it's the
they stay because of all the things they
can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an Easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning
[Music]
I'm talking about the life-and-death
stuff the Oasis the world's most
important economic resource it's nothing
less than a war we're controlling the
future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came here to escape
[Music]
but I found something much bigger than
just myself are you willing to fight
helped us save the oasis
[Music]